[Music]
we are learning a few new details about
Northern Nevada plane crash that killed
all five people on that flight it
happened near Stagecoach last month the
NTSB says the company Guardian flights
was conducting a medical flight when the
plane came apart mid-air according to a
preliminary report conducted by the FAA
the last contact from the pilot
indicated that the plane was climbing to
a little more than fifteen thousand feet
now the controller at that time
instructed the pilot to maintain flight
level and issued a caution for light to
moderate turbulence the pilot
acknowledged the controller and was not
heard from again we are still waiting to
find out what exactly caused that crash